-Welcome back, guys.
It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Oh-ho-ho-ho!
Oh, my goodness.
Now, look, we do this thing
every week.
Oh!
-Whew!
-Oh! We do this thing
every week.
Oh!
We do this thing every week.
-Oh!
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag. Oh.
And we ask you guys --
We do this every week.
-Every week?
-Yeah.
And we ask you guys
to respond to it.
Since 4/20 was this week,
I sent out the #StonerThoughts
and I asked you guys to tweet
out a funny "high idea"
that you or
someone you know had.
-Right.
-Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
We love playing "Hashtags."
Thank you for following up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now I thought I'd share some of
my favorite "StonerThoughts"
responses from you guys.
This first one
is from @lyssbrooke273.
She says...
"When can we read this?"
This is from @grksmileygrl.
-Mm!
-She says...
-[ Imitates explosion ]
-You got to go, man.
You got to go.
-This is from @WichitaKat.
She said...
Oh!
-Peppers?!
-Jalapeños?! Oh, man!
This is, like --
This is the best sandwich.
-You got to be done.
Oh! What?!
-One more topping?! Oh, man!
This's from @Longmatey80.
-Longmatey80.
-They say...
Whew!
-Whoa, man!
-This one's from @catarina v d.
-Oh, boy.
That's not a good --
That's not a good name.
-What are you talk...
-Catarina v d.
Wow!
-Valentine's Day.
-Oh, sure.
Yeah, that's when you get it.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
-I don't know.
It's probably her initials
or something.
-Yeah, sure.
A lot of penicillin.
Catarina v d.
Is that a strain?
-No!
-"You've got catarina v d."
-No.
-[ Russian accent ]
"There's no cure."
-Valentine's Day.
-Oh, Valentine's Day.
-I'm assuming.
-Okay. I'm sorry.
-She says...
Oh, this is great.
This one is from
@thestrawbryfrog.
They say...
-Wow!
-Yeah.
[ Fingers snapping ]
-That's deep.
-That's deep, man.
And the water is deep.
-Water is deep.
Right now, Matthew McConaughey's
head is spinning around.
-Yeah.
-Whoa!
[ Thudding ]
-Oh! Ow! Oh!
Uhlh!!
-Oh!
-U-H-L-H -- Uhlh!
[ Laughter ]
-This is one's from
@gxbbybrxcho.
How come you haven't tweeted
at me, man?
-Yeah, man.
Well, okay, what's your --
-@Gxbbybrxcho.
-Okay, that's a little fast.
Can you send it to me?
-What's your problem, man?
You don't tweet at me ever.
-Ever.
-It's rude almost.
Do you want my -- Write it.
-Let me write it down.
-Gxbbybrxcho.
-Got it.
-I still haven't heard from you.
I just think -- I don't know --
you weren't raised well.
-Oh, somehow,
you got blocked by mistake.
My kids blocked you.
-Oh, well, then tweet me now.
-Oh, my phone broke.
-You have a flip phone?
-Yeah, I have a flip phone.
It flipped out.
-You need two hands to close it?
-Yeah, it's a giant phone.
[ Imitates creaking ]
[ Imitates beeping ]
-Wait. That's the alien signal
from "Close Encounters."
-Yeah.
[ Vocalizes "Close Encounters"
of the Third Kind" tones ]
Wait. Is that E.T.'s phone?
-Yeah, he phoned.
He got it from home.
-That's why
he didn't phone home?
-Yeah, because I had his phone.
-The whole movie could have been
solved if you --
-I'm not giving it back.
"Elliott! Elliott!"
Shut up.
Glowing finger. Get out of here!
-Supposed to be a genius, right?
-What a jerk.
-Yeah, he's supposed
to be so smart.
-Yeah, smartest alien. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, learn to say,
"Can I have my phone back?"
Just ask.
-Yeah, ask.
-Don't be rude.
-Yeah, use your words.
-Thank you.
-Then he gets drunk.
-Oh, he's a mess.
-Ridiculous.
-He's a mess.
-He's ridiculous.
No wonder his parents left him.
-♪ Come back again ♪
♪ I want you to be next time ♪
♪ But home is
the best place of all ♪
That's kind of rubbing it
in a little bit.
Neil Diamond is, like --
He's rubbing it in E.T.'s face.
-Yeah.
-♪ Home is the best place ♪
He's like, "Yeah, I know that."
-Yeah.
-"I'm trying go home, dude."
-"I'm trying to phone it."
-Yeah.
Why don't you sing
"Love on the Rocks"
or one of the hits?
You're gonna rub it in.
-♪ A hard life ♪
-♪ You better get home ♪
♪ Don't you miss home? ♪
"What is this?"
-"I miss home."
-"I feel like
he's talking to me.
It's my first concert
I've ever seen."
-"He directed the song at me.
I feel it's kind of
bittersweet."
-"I can't stop crying."
What's Neil Diamond's
problem, man?
Alright, so, she says...
-Ooh!
-This one is from @MinusTheFire.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, her-she.
-Yeah, Her-shey's.
-Him-he's.
Nice!
-Holy moley.
-Mind blown!
-This one is from
@SherylSchultz1.
She says...
-"You're under arrest, ma'am."
-This is from @RyanBartholomee.
He says...
There you go, man.
That's pretty good.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites, go to...